[Music]
Morrison farming was formed in 2008 um
prior to that I was farming in
partnership with my brother Richard and
my Father John and and um and we were on
half of the original uh Family Farm
since um since 1864 and over the other
side of the road uh was a distant cousin
gram uh working away battling Away by
himself on the other half of the
original business so so we'd always sort
of thought well it would be nice to to
get the original land back together as
one piece conflict can be an interesting
part of um of Family Farms I guess um I
guess um we have our moments uh at
Morrison farming uh like like like a lot
of families so so but look one of the
great things that that alleviates a lot
of the tension or or some of the
conflict anyway is the fact that um is
that we now have a bigger area um from
450 acres we're now up to 35,000 Acres
so we're not living and working in each
other's Pockets we also have um have
have different skill sets and interests
within the farming business so so each
of the each of the directors uh has
looks after different portfolios and
oversees those Parts sure they have to
um turn up to the the Morrison farming
meetings and and and justify their
performance and that they've reached
their kpis um but we all have the um the
freedom to to to work uh with ourselves
or or or with others and um work on work
on the portfolios that we're in charge
of